[موسيقى]
بلشت بالقلم ارسم على الورق العادي حتى
كنت ارسم موجيء الحطب بالليل الدنيا على
كتله العواصف تنقطع الكهرباء تشوف بس
هالنار
وخيال هالنار على الحيط
تعرفت على معهد الرسم وبلشت بالصف عنده
بوقتها انكسر الحاجز الخوف بيني وبين
التلوين الزيت وانطلقت اكيد ما في هويه
بعد
برسم اي شيء بحبه
الاهل بيعرفوا غير هيك ما كان خلي حدا
يعرف اني برسم صرت تحس انه عم ياخذوا مني
كمان كان عندي خوفه من النقد
مسؤول بمركز المعارض بيتصل فيه وبقول لي
راح نندم لك تقدم في لوحاتك بوقتها ما في
رؤوسوف
الخوف اللي كان عندي لانه قالوا لي انه
هاي المعرض مشارك فيه تقريبا من مختلف دول
العالم
مشاركتي كانت كتير رائعه هيدا كان مفصل
اني رجعت للرسم بزخم وبقوي اكتر وبطل عندي
هذا الخوف
اللوحه اللي كنت عم بشتغل عليها اللي غيرت
هيك مجرى الرسم عندي كنت اقعد على الارض
قبالها ولا لا انت غلبتيني انا ما راح فيي
ارسمك ما قدرت كفات وجلغمتها كلها يعني
دهنتها كلها رسم
بعد شي كم شهر رجعت جبت الكونفرس ولزعتها
على الحيط وبلشت اشتغل فيها وكانت تحدي
كان موجود بس بلشت تبين معي ملامحها عليت
الموسيقى ورقصت
وكنت كتير مبسوط وكفيتها بمتعه لا توصف
وبعتبرها لليوم هي الماستر بيس تبعي
تحدي هو موجود عند الانسان اذا كان في
موهبه وفي شغف عنده لشيء اكيد بيوصل
المطرح ما هو حابب يوصل
[موسيقى]